سنوات العده واجهه النساء الايرانيات شتى
انواع القمع الذي مرسى ضده من قبل النظام
الايراني في احدث صوره حتى التكنولوجيا
تستغل في مراقبه الايرانيات وفقا لموقع
المتخصص بتكنولوجيا قيامه اجهزه الامن
الايرانيه باعتقال النساء حتى بعد ايام
العده من مخالفتهن قواعد اللباس
على الوجه الصينيه المنشا هذه التقنيه
يمكنها التعرف على وجوه المخالفين
بالاستعانه بقاعده بيانات الهويه الوطنيه
ثم اعتقاله كما انماط الاعتقالات تظهر ان
تقنيه التعرف على الوجوه ماتت قيد
الاستخدام بشكل فعلي في ايران وهو الامر
ذاته الذي سبق ان تحدث عنه تقرير نشره
موقع في نوفمبر عام 2020 قال حينها الى
الصين زودت ايران بانظمه مراقبه جماعيه
ذات التغطيه كبيره حيث تم وضع ما يقارب 15
مليون نقطه كاميرات مراقبه في المدن
الكبيره بايرام
الشرطه تلاحق الناشطين والمتظاهرين خاصه
النساء اللواتي لا يضعن الحجاب حيث يجري
اعتقالهن في منازلهن بعد ايام
الشرطه الاخلاقيه والمخبرين السريين الذين
قدرت اعدادهم سبعه الاف عمل سري عام 2016
حسب نيويورك ما هي الا جزء من طرق الترغيب
والتخويف التي يستخدمها النظام الاراضي ضد
المواطنين
بتظاهرات المستمره لاشهر قبل النظام بحمله